foreign
let's go to Lisa in Missoula what's up
Lisa
hi what's happening
hi not much good morning good morning to
you is the world uh spinning in your
area
um yeah it seems to be seems to be good
over here why do y'all keep letting all
those balloons go over there what are
you doing
hahaha I played no part in any of it
sure sure Lisa
we're on to you hey uh before you
continue your question with Lisa you
don't see this and I want to make sure
that y'all have this discussion on
Lisa's email she signed off as proud dog
mom and continue oh
and that was on purpose and I'm sorry
Hey listen we all need to live in our
own little delusions and if this is the
one for you then so be it and thank you
he looks really cute in a sweater that's
all I'm gonna say
uh uh Kelly just carries like a small
vial of gas in her purse and so when she
sees any small flame she's like ooh and
then she just dumps gasoline on it just
to watch things burn so I love her for
it are you calling about being in dog
mom please say yes
what's up
yeah well um at the end of the day the
question is and just um and
acknowledging how anxiety changes I'm
I'm wanting some really practical tips
on on how I can get this under control
and then
um secondary to uh that because I
emailed in and my question kind of
changed after we had scheduled this but
um learning to trust my spouse how to
relearn how to trust him when I feel
like with all this anxiety I can't even
trust myself anymore what do you do
um well there's a backstory and I
prepped some notes okay I'll run through
it quickly okay
so um back story depending on how I
interpret the the questions I'm a seven
two and eight on the Asus exam
um I I hear that I see that but I also
acknowledge that I turned it around I
did the work
um life is good
um I'm living the quote end quote middle
class American dream I have a great dog
uh great job great health right
um I've always struggled with anxiety
um I well I say always I didn't know I
was struggling with anxiety until maybe
three years ago okay can I pause it can
I pause you right here can I pause you
right here yeah yeah
if you were with me right now I would
say ask you if I had permission to give
you a hug
and what I would do is not in a weird
creepy way
um
but I would want to give you a hug for
like 15 or 20 seconds past where it got
awkward
to where your shoulders would finally
drop for a second
you just you just rattled off a really
common response to Childhood trauma
which is I will out achieve this thing
I'll outrun it with my house size square
footage and I'll outrun it with my
salary I'll run it with my how good
looking my husband is I'll outrun it
with the car that I drive
and it will catch you and it will bury
you right
yeah it feels right and I think that's
exactly what's happened well you said
here's here's the big tell for me is
your anxiety keeps moving on you
yeah and it's it's
some people have a phobia about a
particular room in their house because
that's where their child passed away
like they can't go in that room their
body is identified they put a GPS pin in
that room this room's not safe
that's not what your body's doing
your body has identified the world is
unsafe
and as soon as you get a grasp on
something
because you're so strong you're out
running a seven or eight on the aces
you're so strong you're able to grab
hold of these things and wrestle it to
the ground and then kind of like a like
a balloon animal it squirts out
somewhere else and something else it
jumps on something else
and it's because you're not healing from
the center and I'm gonna even push you
further and say
I've come to believe with all the
reviews of the literature and all of the
Swan diving into all the narrow
chemicals and all that all the stuff
that only a few of us nerds really care
about
at the end of the day healing from
anxiety
teaching your body that you're safe is
about Connection in a relationship
and traumatized people
that's the demon of trauma is
it makes relationships the the the
monster and so your body identifies
relationships as something I can't get
into and if you don't have relationships
you can't breathe
yeah and so then it makes everything it
spins your alarms and says we can't
breathe we can't breathe then you're
like oh I'm gonna reach out to my
husband because I love him and then your
body's like no
and then like a good husband he goes and
does something stupid
or a whole bunch of things stupid or in
a weird gross dance
he starved for connection too
and he's got a woman that he loves who's
sleeping next to him and he can feel the
nuclear reactor in her chest
and he starts to think well maybe it's
me
and then somebody somewhere lights him
up
it makes him feel a little bit more
alive am I onto something tell me I'm
right or wrong
you're heading in the right direction
but I got a hard left turn for you okay
bring it
yeah so I've been with my husband for
five years total two and a half of those
married
um intimacy at the beginning was really
great it did taper off pretty early
um and yeah why well well I'll get get
to there because I think I finally
okay
it's been an issue ongoing a lot of
fights and I've been unfortunately
growing some resentment about it
um while we were still dating he had a
bit of a a text Affair if you will an
emotional affair
um that I I was able to heal from and
forgive him and and we moved on uh
it was yeah it was a whole thing
um okay so yeah you're speaking trauma
language I'm gonna call it every time I
hear it okay I didn't have a bit of an
affair
he cheated on you
yeah okay yeah and you are great at
peacekeeping and you are great at
minimizing
yep okay yeah
yep no thank you all right and then so
you went through with marriage you
forgave them you said we're gonna we're
gonna make this make a run at this thing
and then yep
yep flirtation at an affair
um that he swears up and down was
short-lived nothing physical happened
and um during this confrontation he then
proceeded to admit to me that for the
entirety that I have known him and for
as long as he can remember he's had a
porn addiction
um and he works on the road and um you
know he's gone three nights a week and
he's been struggling with that and I'm
just I I feel like maybe that's why
intimacy is failing but he's also been
lying to me the entire time I've known
him and
I'm
I don't even know how to like close my
dialogue for the backstory because I
just I'm at such a loss I don't I don't
I'm Bamboozled yeah
um yeah so there's no surprise that
you're anxious because your body's been
trying to get your attention for a long
time
that it did it since something was not
right at home
and
on top of as much trauma as you've
experienced you learned at an early age
you need to take those feelings and bury
them in the backyard because they just
get you hurt
we've got things to solve we've got
things to achieve we've got things to
crush and kill and drag home we don't
have time for this
digging into what's making me feel
uncomfortable
right and so good for you you learned
how to move on right and not good for
you once again the person who's at the
bottom is you here's what's so
disorienting man and it breaks my heart
for you you've built your entire
identity on top of this trauma not from
a place of healing but from a place of
accomplishment and achievement and I can
do all things Lisa will take control
and
they can't control this
and so now you've lost troll trust in
Lisa
how did I miss this I've been prepped
for this you see what I'm saying
yeah
can I just tell you I'm sorry
thanks how did your conversation end
I know I've I've listened to a lot of
your show
um probably almost every episode and I I
re-listened to the ones I need to hear
again and I read and I do the things and
I know I either have to be all in or all
out and I do really love this guy and so
I've chosen to be all in
um and
I it's it seems good now and I but it's
not and I can't just I can't keep
pretending let me tell you where I
failed you okay oh yeah I should add I
should add a caveat you gotta be all in
or you got to be all out
but sometimes when the wound is deep
when the wound hurts when there's been
years of systemic lying and covering up
and multiple affairs
sometimes I can't be all in right now
and I should have added that a long time
ago and I'm sorry
for the first time in your life you've
got to find a place where you feel safe
enough to say what you actually think
and what you're actually feeling
I'm pissed you should be sorry say it
say it Carl ramrod say it
I am so freaking pissed yeah keep going
I
want to punch him in the face I mean
that's not that's not a solution but I
do I mean I'm considering it keep going
I just there's got to be something
better out there right there's not
something but like better energy better
existence and like why why what was so
wrong with me that this had to happen
again there it is and listen to me very
very carefully
your husband's dealing with demons that
have nothing to do with you
and it would actually in your mind be
easier if this was about you because
then you could have something to fix
your husband's lying to you because
something's wrong with him
your husband's cheating on you because
he's wrestling with his own issues
and maybe I just just for full honesty
and it may be that he has been with you
and he can't figure out a way to connect
with you
okay
my estimation that doesn't give license
for what's happening but it might
provide a context okay it's not an
excuse but it might say like I'm trying
and it didn't work out instead of having
the courage to say this isn't a good
relationship for me he went ahead and
married you and instead of being honest
with you and saying Hey I want to work
through this thing together he lied to
you and instead of saying I feel
I don't like who I'm becoming in this
relationship he went and found somebody
else that says well I like you
yeah okay yeah
this isn't you
what do I do set that thing that you
tell me
I don't know that's why I called you I
don't know I'm at a loss like do you
want to be married to him
yeah he's dumb but I really like him
it's not dumb don't apologize for that
um Gene a break
well that's the confusing part is I want
nothing more but to be around him right
now
is that reality or is that your trauma
I have no idea that's it's confusing I
I I don't know do you have sexual abuse
in your past
none that I can remember okay well and I
was listening to one of your shows and I
um started dating quote unquote at 14
and my first boyfriend was 18 and
according to you that's not healthy so
maybe
they're not great
um
do do
somebody leave when you were a kid
yeah so
we talk a lot about it and I don't
exactly I don't know who if I've
mentioned on the show surely I have
we all know about fight or flight
response we all know about fighter
fighter freeze response a fourth yeah
uncommon one that we don't talk about a
lot is fawn
fight flight or freeze or Fawn where I'm
gonna nuzzle up
and become extra lovable to the person
who's hurting me because maybe that'll
keep him from hurting me again
and I'm asking you is that what you're
doing
are you so terrified in your at the
cellular level that he's gonna leave if
you take a break
that you can't imagine a world where
somebody else leaves and so you're going
to continue to get cheated on continue
to get lied to you're going to continue
to wade into his storms
because the alternative is you might end
up by yourself and it's not I can't do
that again
please
I don't want you to be mad at yourself
for loving him you're not there's
nothing wrong with you you're not broken
it's your husband and I don't want you
to like man anybody's like oh you should
just leave him and shut up nobody you
only person who can answer that question
is you
but I want to be honest about
um
sometimes you gotta you gotta take a
break from sparring session because
you're hurt
um
what does uh regaining trust look like
for you like if you snapped your fingers
and said this is how I'm gonna start
trusting this guy again what would that
look like
morning
um
if he looked at anything overnight
or question him when he interacts with
women at work that's going to be a long
long time
yeah
and I'll tell you right now I want you
to keep asking that question because
you're going to be tempted to stop
asking that question because you want to
make him feel uncomfortable anymore you
don't want to hassle him or nag him and
you're going to take your feelings once
again and shove them so far down that
you body can't breathe
the difference here is I want you to
call it out I'm going to ask you every
single day for the next three months
we'll revisit it
but the asking is one part what if he
just lies because he's been doing it for
so long that's where he was about to say
you have to have the if then statement
if you lie to me again I'm out yeah
yeah if you
text another woman that you're not
married to that's not me I'm out
yeah
I don't personally I don't believe him
that he hasn't been with somebody
yeah and that's just my default setting
in that kind of situation multiple times
over multiple years especially knowing
I've got a wife who's particularly
sensitive to this particular issue
um you gotta prove to me otherwise I'm
just going with
if it's if it you know smells like a
fire it's probably fire
what else does he not tell you the truth
about and don't say nothing because I
won't believe you
I have
I've been questioning that same thing I
I mean when he tells me he loves me or
he likes me or he is sexually attracted
to me it all feels like lies now
yeah and that's a weird thing there's
some really remarkable research in
writing um probably the most eloquent
writer on this is Esther perel
um
and what got her down the rabbit hole
that she ended up becoming like one of
the most important voices in the world
on was she kept meeting with clients who
had really extraordinary marriages
and then someone would go cheat
and it wasn't about sexual attraction it
was about financial attraction and it
wasn't about they didn't have the same
values and they had just helped
somebody's they just sat together while
one of their parents had died of cancer
like they'd been through hell and back
together they were a good marriage
and ultimately that's where I take that
that's she's the one who gave me that
idea that I think is so profound and I
continue to see it over and over and
over again once she illuminated it which
is
most of the time people cheat most of
the time people go seeking stimulation
somewhere else from somebody else
whether it's texting whether it's
um somebody's only fan site whether it's
pornography whether it's actually
meeting somebody and creating new
relationship whether it's just a
one-night hookup
it's because they don't like who they've
become in their relationship
yeah
and so I think the challenge here might
be you deciding this is who I want to be
married to
and giving him a sense of these are the
values this is the person that I want to
be married to somebody who's got enough
courage to go deal this crap with a
counselor somebody who goes and to a
Celebrate Recovery Group or somebody who
meets with a group of men every week to
hold each other accountable
somebody who goes nine months in our
house with no internet
someone who doesn't have a cell phone
whatever that looks like
yeah and I want you to stop apologizing
for
wanting some thresholds of trust in your
marriage and in your home because you're
not the one that took them out
you're not maybe it was in the text
and even if it was that's the trauma
talking
and Trauma right like it just it
happened and it was so out of my control
like it's whatever moving on and listen
and we do I've done a terrible job also
on my show over the course talking about
post-traumatic growth
foreign people become incredibly strong
and Incredibly connected and become
incredible leaders and have incredible
families
following trauma
post-traumatic growth is a very very
real thing so I don't want to minimize
it you're not broken forever
I gotta look at I gotta look at the
epidemiological data right you're more
likely to have X and Y and Z growing up
that's just a fact that just is and
when I look around my community most
everybody I see experience some pretty
hard stuff growing up on a big scale or
on a little scale
hey man there's some pretty amazing
people who've come from some pretty
amazing places and I count you as one of
them
I would love to see you talk to a
counselor not to even heal from
childhood trauma I'd love to see you
meet with a counselor to begin to listen
to Lisa's voice for the first time in
your whole life
would you do that
yeah yeah
to learn how to create boundaries
and not apologize for them
yeah
I want you to pick up
um Nidra to Webb t-a-w-e-b her book is
called find boundaries find peace I
think is the title
um I just read it recently it is
outstanding
but I think it's a book worthy of you
reading it okay
okay
I also want you to hang on the line I'm
going to send you a copy of on your past
change your future and
um
just as my gift to you
and I want you to read that as well but
I want you to before the day is over I
want you to call a counselor
no because something's wrong with you
but because you got some new skills to
learn
and the new skills to learn are
trusting Lisa's body for the first time
ever
learning to identify when your body's
telling you you're not safe or you're
disconnected which it's been trying to
get your attention for a long time
that's anxiety
and three
how to practice and set and Implement
boundaries and then hold them in your
new marriage because your marriage is
new now what was is over now you and
your husband get to build something
completely new and y'all got to figure
out what that's going to look like
he needs to go see somebody too because
he's struggling with feeling dead inside
and that's not on you that's on him
he's gonna have to do that work to
decide why he keeps self-sabotaging and
why he's become so unhappy with himself
in his role as your husband
that's his journey to do and you'll
probably end up in marriage counseling
which would be fantastic
but you're right to be upset and you're
right to be heartbroken and you're white
you're right to want to start swinging
all those feelings are right
you just got that scary scary terrifying
question what am I gonna do now
and I'll walk with you every step of the
way and I'm happy to talk to him too if
he wants to give me a shout thanks for
your bravery